pedro castillo y keiko fujimori agua y
aceite él es líder de izquierda y ella
de derecha por lo que las posturas de
los ciudadanos están muy divididas no
vamos a perder de estas libertades no
vamos a tener a un dictador
tenemos que pelear por la democracia no
queremos ser un venezuela no queremos
ser un cubano queremos ser un knick
aragua queremos mantener nuestras
libertades eso es todo los simpatizantes
de keiko han vinculado castillo con el
grupo terrorista sendero luminoso en más
de una ocasión además dicen que sus
planes de gobierno amenazan a las
empresas transnacionales y organismos
constitucionales de hecho parte de sus
ofrecimientos son estatizar el país y
redactar una nueva constitución por otro
lado el antifujimorismo ha cogido mucha
fuerza en estas elecciones es una
organización criminal con gobernado con
su padre dijo algo cuando su padre se
iba a esterilizar a las mujeres del
campo en contra de su voluntad no fue
cómplice y no solamente eso quiere tomar
el poder porque sabe lo que le viene
detrás del crepe de la carne
el hito gravísimo que cometió los
peruanos están cansados de ser
gobernados por corruptos y keiko ha
estado involucrada en el caso la valla
pto
por eso se adentran en el tema de las
elecciones ante el futuro que se les
avecina ha aumentado el interés de los
peruanos en la campaña electoral
respecto a lo que vimos en la primera
vuelta que era un elector desconectado
totalmente de la elección ahora si vemos
mayor preocupación mayor seguimiento en
la campaña ante los extremos que
presentan los candidatos al balotaje por
la presidencia de perú firmaron un
acuerdo para respetar el orden
constitucional del país sin embargo hay
dudas de que cumplan su promesa